okay so this is how a mannequin i'm here
at the World Economic Forum want to just
talk about some experiences have also
gone basically the the mood is rather
town lots of talk about the euro and is
Greece go to stay in it and I think of
course Greece's I wanna stay in it but
you know you hear lots of heads of state
lots of politicians saying we need to
get our house in order or not I just
don't understand what that means for a
politician to say let's get our house in
order I think the right idea is to give
it a scripture for solutions and not
just say these giants are platitudes so
I the issue is we just don't have a plan
yet and it's kind of complex so so the
u.s. drive interest rates lower you
imagine people talking about oh it's
employment and they're saying of
employment is we're losing in America so
these are our economy write the answers
the Fed just put a giant stamp on the
fact that there is no economy in America
in fact remains that interest rates in
America or near zero or r 0 because
Leslie economy the euro is going to go
to zero just not just yet so interest
rates in Europe one percenter gonna keep
dropping them because the German
prescription is good for Germany the
German prescription nautical for Italy
it's certainly not good for Spain and
it's not good for Portugal so Germany's
going to certain hand cards and for them
to suggest other countries should play
there are different cards the way
germany's playing their cards just
doesn't make any sense so i think that's
going to cause lots of this you know
lots of pain between everyone but
ultimately mariotti is going to cut
rates and just try to tender same
prescription resting to drive the
economy in europe it's pretty much done
either way it's got to go and no so
we'll do you wanna stay together shores
or anybody here really talking about it
i think people like to banter about
things but i don't think anybody here
really is taking seriously at the euro
is not permitted to be together how they
do it and how they keep it together my
opinion i think ultimately will be a pan
your
in dat tax means glad one or two percent
on top the v8 8 all of you and then
they'll tell each country that money is
going to go into the Stabilization Fund
and when we get payback for helping
whatever country we help you can have
you money so each country will go then
it's not just general carrying the ball
consumer-related Germany's not going to
carry the ball it's got to be spread
across here so I think if you set it to
a government official let me freak out
and then thats related to new things
you're right